the black knight is actually threatening
to move itself to the e6 square
attacking the bishop and the pawn on d4
but he's not given time nope sepenko now
jumping forward with his own knight
attacking the black rook if the
blackrook moves itself if it keeps
itself on the g file it has to as it
does then the white rook might start
swinging across at some point um the
black rook is almost trapped actually um
there we go the white bishop just moves
the black rook forced to run away from
the attack and now i think yes panko can
just trap that black rook
look at this the black rook entrenched
between white pieces and it's gonna be
game over yep the black rook was
i mean simply nowhere to go it gives
itself up for the white knight and we've
seen a result a fist pump from essepenko
he's won he's beating the world champion
what a result from the 19 year old
making his debut in the meltdown
champions chester winning game three
against magnus carlsen the world
champion
losing his very first game